welcome it's fantastic to be here and
Simon thank you so much for joining us
here at DocuSign we're really thrilled
to have you here today thanks for having
me appreciate it so hey for the few you
know five percent of Doc designers who
don't already know you because of the
incredible success you've had with your
books and you're speaking can you maybe
just give a little bit of background to
who you are and what you do and maybe
give us some insight why you think
you've become so influential
well um I have a vision of the world
that does not yet exist I imagine a
world in which the vast majority of
people wake up every single morning
inspired feel safe wherever they are and
end the day fulfilled by the work that
they do I believe that leaders are the
best tool that we have to build that
world so I've built a career where I've
found a way to support and celebrate
those leaders that I believe are more
likely to build that world I do it all
kinds of ways I've written books about
it given talks about it and stuff like
this fantastic it's easy to see why that
world view would be so inspiring not to
use your catchphrase but you know let's
start at the Y let's talk about your
early work and and really what I think
really captured the imagination of so
many people that was again so inspiring
as you sort of really encapsulated such
a core concept can you maybe just share
with this group a little bit about what
you mean by why and and why that's so
important well it was a bunch of years
ago where I sort of lost my passion for
my own work
and I discovered the this naturally
occurring pattern based on how the how
the human brain makes decisions that
every single one of us knows what we do
we know the jobs we do we know the
products we sell the services we offer
as companies
um some can articulate how we do those
things these are the things that you may
say are your differentiating value
propositions the things that make you
different or stand out from the crowd
but very very few people and very very
few organizations can clearly articulate
why they do what they do and by why I
mean to make money that's a result by
why I mean what's your purpose what's
your cause what's your belief why does
your company exist on a level beyond
your product you know why should we get
out of bed every morning why should
anybody care and what I learned is that
the most inspiring the most influential
the most Innovative companies and
organizations and individuals all think
act and communicate the exact same way
everybody from Martin Luther King to
Apple Computers they start with why and
so when I first realized this it not
only profoundly changed my own view of
my life and my organization but I talked
about it and I guess it resonated with
other people too
yeah a lot of other people for sure and
when people say to me you know what is
the doctor why I've talked a lot about
you know a vision we have of trying to
make the world more agreeable
and I think um I think that sometimes
captures imagination but sometimes I
also have people say well what does that
really mean you know what does it mean
to make the world more agreeable if you
were sort of a expert in this field
which you are and you thought a little
bit about DocuSign in that construct and
what's your reaction to making the world
more agreeable as a one what's what's
good where do you see gaps and let's
chat about that
so for me a good y has two pieces
um there's a contribution and an impact
to do something so that something
happens
um so like my wife for example is to
inspire people to do the things that
Inspire them so together each of us can
change our world for the better so when
I hear it to make the world more
agreeable what I hear is the so that I
hear the outcome that the world is more
agreeable and the question that it
raises for me is what's your
contribution what's the specific thing
that you're doing to help make the world
more agreeable one of them is that we
provide a technology solution which of
course allows people to come to
agreement and we make it much easier
than it used to be to facilitate uh
those sort of if you will sometimes
contractual like uh
people make and and have a way for them
to do it in more of a sort of a win-win
capacity because it takes a lot of the
complexity out of the process allows
people to really focus on the core of
that agreement we also think there's
another side which is there's a broader
almost environmental impact right we
think about our piece of digital
transformation uh as making the world a
better place not just because people
come to agreement
screw in more easily but they do it in
an environmentally more sensitive way so
that's kind of how I think about that
that why in making the world more
agreeable give me critique well there's
two parts one is you know punny uh
Visions or punny wise like a a a a a
chemical company saying it's all about
our chemistry get it get it you know
it's the same kind of thing which is one
of the problems is is because the people
who come to work every day they're more
familiar with one definition and then so
it becomes the product being in the
hierarchy higher than the more human
element of it and you really want any
other order you know the product serves
the cause not the other way around which
leads to the second point which is your
whole description of it was largely
based in product for me you know a why
is about the history of the company it's
the founding of the organization a good
y comes from the past
um and is is disconnected from the
product the product is the primary means
by which you know you're building upon
your why or advancing your cause but
it's not a it's not a description of the
product but one of the things that's
happened with DocuSign is we don't sort
of think about it as we're one of the
players in a particular business we
actually sort of created an industry if
you will or a signature and those famous
report uh some years back the Forester
put out and they said docusign's become
a verb so people don't think about it as
the product per se they think about the
ACT of creating any signature or a doc
design so I think that gives us some
benefit and allows us to get transcended
as you said the product but also can
become a hurdle for us because then it
embeds so much in that you know the
product ask
yeah I mean it's sort of the innovator's
Dilemma right which is you're a Pioneer
and you know you become the generic you
know you become the kleenex or the Q-tip
but eventually you know when there's a
Marketplace others will do it and those
Industries will mature when JetBlue
first showed up as an airline they were
the first airline to make all of the
seats on their planes and in leather and
put uh TVs in every seat and I remember
that was their advertising for quite a
while it's like everyone gets a leather
seat everyone gets a TV and then it you
know it turned out to be a thing and it
before too long every Airline had all
leather seats and every Airline had
seats on every plane and yet I remember
the advertising JetBlue was still
talking about how they invented it
nobody really cared anymore because it
was now generic you know I think what
makes Innovative companies Innovative is
that is that they recognize that they
create something it become everybody
else is the follower and now you have
the opportunity to create it again how
do you think about that mission or the
why how that translates into the
strategy great companies especially the
ones that continue to innovate year over
year they think of their companies less
like companies think of themselves more
like social movements and so that why
becomes a filter are we doing this are
we building upon this and unfortunately
success becomes a great liability for a
lot of organizations where all of a
sudden the thing that inspired them and
drove them in the early days the thing
that was the foundation for all their
Innovation gets replaced by quarterly or
annually annual goals
you know short-term incentive structures
and unfortunately that Foundation that
very inspiring Foundation becomes
forgotten dare I say so it has to be a
filter for for decision making and a
rallying cry for people to try and
figure out how to advance but in in
Leaders Eat Last it was something that
spoke to me more about my own sort of
role and who I wanted to be you sort of
maybe synopsis a little bit some of your
core thinking around that work I was
going through a period in my own career
where I was struggling to trust people
um and didn't know who to trust and I
know trust is important everybody keeps
telling us trust is important but they
don't tell us what trust is or how it's
built simultaneously I just happened to
be spending time with folks in uniform
with folks in the military and I kept
meeting these people who would willingly
risk their lives to save the lives of
people they didn't even like whereas in
business you know we didn't want to even
want to give up credit for things let
alone Our Lives I started asking the
question how do I get people like that
at work
and my original theory was that they're
just better people and better people are
drawn to this life of service which is
fine why you find the disproportionately
high number of these high trusting High
sacrifice people and the more I started
to learn the more I started to
investigate the more I realized I was
completely wrong it's not actually about
the person it's about the environment
government
you can take a good person and put them
in a bad environment and they will do
bad things conversely you can take
someone who may have been perceived as
untrustworthy you can change their
environment and they can change their
lives and become valuable members of a
team and who's responsible for setting
the environment leaders leaders set the
environment so if you can create an
environment biologically trust will
follow super powerful and I want it sort
of segues for me into the values that we
have Three core values trust is hugely
important that you know our customers
come to us and say Here's this
incredibly powerful data we have and
we're trusting you use it right you
protect it for us but it's also the way
we feel about our employees right we
want employees to feel that the
company's looking out for them you know
and they can feel that we have a
trust-based relationship around their
career but we also talk about
responsibility as our second you know
core value and this is the the sort of
back to your decision-making processes
do you make decisions in a way that you
treat people equally and fairly and and
do people say yes whether I agree or
disagree with every single decision and
then the last one
um love as a corporate value and I
always start off by saying if you had
said to me before I was a doctor sign
would I ever work at a company where
love would be one of our Three core
values I would have said no I don't
think that would happen when you meet
someone that you don't know and you tell
them you work at DocuSign the vast
majority of people say I love DocuSign
and then they tell you their story how
do you think about those values well if
love is the one that everybody loves
then maybe that one should go first
especially if it guides others I mean
yeah trust for me is a tricky one when
we put it on the wall as value because
we can't instruct people to trust and
values have to be things we do I like
when values are written as verbs you
know it's not innovate you can't like
walk into someone's office and say
please innovate you know but you can say
think of the problem differently you
know honesty you can't put honesty on
the wall it's tell the truth and trust
is one of those weird ones because trust
is a result you know you can't tell
people trust me it doesn't really work
that way in fact the least trustworthy
people are the ones who tell you that
they're the most trustworthy right
um what generates trust is when we
actively work to make others feel safe
the result is trust so trust is value
though not intellectually wrong it's
very hard to execute because you can't
tell people to trust it's not an
instruction and I I'm a great believer
that as I said the best values are are
often written as actions as verbs
because you you can tell people you can
do them you can hold people accountable
to them and you can even measure them
and build incentive structures around
them I like that I think I think we have
work to do on that we've had these this
model for a few years now and all things
need a look you know and they need to be
reviewed and make sure we're there when
we talk about bringing people into the
company we talk about culture fit for
sure and we want to think that they're
going to have that value match to be
successful here but I also think we
implicitly have a little bit what you
said we sort of expect that that person
gets here
they're gonna get it you know they're
they're within the range that they'll be
able to flourish in the community like
this and sometimes we're mistaken I
think the vast majority of the time we
make it work how do you think about in
in sort of action mode
understanding whether people really are
you know living to our values and how do
you act on it uh when you sort of sense
that there might be a gap well I mean
and like you I've been talking for years
about cultural fit but you know fit can
be sometimes very passive and I like to
think now more about cultural Contra
contribution which is if someone fits
our values if they believe what we
believe we want them to take our values
and go and and and build upon them we
want them to go make things based on our
values help contribute to the culture
make it grow now one of the ways you
hold people accountable to values is you
know recognition and reward you you get
the behavior you reward
I did some work with uh the Navy Seals
uh the director of training for that
group drew a graph for me you know
performance and trust and what they
learned was that the high performer of
low trust is a toxic team member and
they would rather have a medium
performer sometimes even a low performer
of high trust than that high TR than the
high performer of low trust and if you
think about business we have a million
metrics to measure someone's performance
and we have negligible to no metrics to
measure someone's trustworthiness and
the irony is trust is actually a very
easy thing to measure go to any team
they'll all point to the same person you
know and by the way likewise if you go
to any team and you ask them who has
your back always they'll also point to
the same person which is your best
natural leader that may not be your your
best individual performer and so it
raises the question are we putting the
right people in leadership positions
because those people are more likely to
engender trust and and perpetuate the
values and it's so funny as you were
just describing you say hey we don't
have this way to get data on the people
who trust I said we do the answer is ask
their colleagues it's just that we don't
normally build those processes but I
talk about this concept of the impact
the success of our employees is three
factors they have to have skills in
smarts and then you take that and you
divide that by your ego and the way I
Define ego is a person with a high ego a
positive ego is one that puts the team
first and so we've got a low score in
forego is someone that's very
self-centric and you take that ratio and
you raise it to the power of how hard
they work no matter how hard you work
if you don't have a good ratio of your
contributions from skills relative to
the ego you bring sometimes it's
actually toxic to your point right so a
person's working really hard but pushing
an agenda that's all about them it it
demoralizes other people around them
does that make sense to you uh
conceptually
I mean in theory yes I mean I think we
we forget that you know we're human and
you know the way we track metrics the
way we measure each other is is if we're
machines now those you know output is
very important but input is really
important too and it's just harder to
measure you know like we talked about
trustworthiness and cultural
contribution and you know creativity
these are things that are in all of us
but we don't know how to measure them
easily and objectively in the short term
um and so yeah philosophically I think
what you're you're you're you're talking
about is right it also reminds me of my
favorite definition of humility
um Bob Gaylord who's the fifth chief
Master Sergeant of the Air Force said
don't confuse humility with meekness
humility is being open to the ideas of
others and I've met some pretty
remarkable powerful uh people in
leadership positions who absolutely have
big egos but they're still open to ideas
of others a healthy ego is thinking
you're good an unhealthy healthy ego is
thinking that you're better than
everyone else
I think that's I think that definitely
uh Taps into your your formula so um I
want to get to your point you just
started talking a lot about the long
term you know super important if you
want to talk a little about the infinite
game and just try again quick little
synopsis and then I got some very
specific things I want to talk to you
about yeah absolutely in the mid 1980s a
philosopher and theologian by the name
of Dr James karst articulated these two
types of games finite games and infinite
games a finite game is defined as known
players fixed rules and an agreed upon
objective football baseball there's
always beginning middle and an end and
if there's a winner then necessarily
there have to be losers
then you have infinite games infinite
games are defined as known and unknown
players the rules are changeable which
means every player can play however they
want and the objective is to stay in the
game as long as possible to perpetuate
the game
turns out where players uh in infinite
games every day of Our Lives whether we
know it or not there's no such thing as
winning global politics for example no
one wins education well it turns out
nobody wins business either you know
there's no such thing as winning
business but if you listen to the
language of so many Business Leaders it
becomes abundantly clear that they don't
know the game they're playing in they
talk about being number one or being the
best or beating their competition and
this is a problem because when we play
with a finite mindset in an infinite
game when we play to win in a game that
has no Finish Line there are some
predictable and consistent outcomes the
big ones being the decline of trust the
decline of cooperation and the decline
of innovation we have to play for the
game we are in and most businesses play
with a finite mindset one of the
challenges uh for how the game gets
defined uh is the the state if you're
talking about for a business the state
of the company we are as you know a
public company and so on the one hand we
have aspiration to think you know
infinite I also have every quarter I
report my earnings to Wall Street and so
now I've got a different game that has a
to your point a very specific timeline
with a very specific metric you know in
order to kind of thrive in the long game
you got to put some wins up uh in the in
the shorter term game to have that
flexibility and right to keep playing I
mean bluntly the best companies ignore
Wall Street you know why are you making
decisions to help some 27 year old
analysts meet their financial objectives
so they can get their bonus you know
fundamentally if you do well and uh they
believe in your vision they'll invest in
you but ultimately like a good customer
the best customers are not the Fairway
their customers they're the loyal ones
that they stick with you through thick
and thin and the same goes for investors
the best investors are the ones who
believe in the management believe in the
vision and understand that you're making
decisions for the long term and are
willing to take some short-term hits and
stick with you because they believe in
you we also have to remember that the
concept of shareholders Supremacy as a
sort of a standard in modern capitalism
is relatively recent and has it actually
been good for innovation in business and
I think the consensus is it hasn't been
well keep in mind now for us every one
of our employees
um is a sheriff right and so it's
important piece so when we have
short-term fluctuations be really
straightforward it impacts them both
positively and negatively so we do have
to factor in that reality last thing I
want to talk to you about that is is
actually about our employees so we got
thousands of docusigners out there
chatting with us one of the things that
I think is interesting is some people
get motivated by that short-term gain
right there are a lot of people who are
competitive here and I'm one of them and
like that concept of a game and a win
and a path to feel that success at the
same time there's a lot of docusigners
that say you know what's inspiring to me
is about I want to be a part of
something that's bigger than myself
those concepts are not mutually
exclusive and being a part of the
infinite game is not the absence of
finite games it's the context within
which those finite games exist and when
we when we think only in short term in
an infinite game like I said you don't
know what it's a part of and at some
point you start saying is this worth it
or what am I doing here is this you know
this is it becomes exhausting quite
frankly
um we have to change the analogies we
have to change the metaphors we overuse
Sports and warning analogies in business
those are finite constructions think of
it more like a lifestyle right let's say
you want to be healthy and there's many
things you have to do to be healthy you
have to eat right you have to sleep you
can absolutely have arbitrary short-term
goals and if I happen to hit my goal on
the right day and the right time I'm
ecstatic but here's the joke I have to
keep exercising and eating healthy For
the Rest of My Life the game hasn't
ended just because I hit a goal what's
more interesting is what happens if you
miss your goal right you know what
happens if you miss your goal
nothing nothing happens because when you
have a vision when you have a just cause
that you're striving for you're making
constant Improvement and if you go back
to our metaphor I'm way healthier now
than I was when I started even if I
missed my goal so the two are not
mutually exclusive you can absolutely
have arbitrary goals it's very exciting
it drives people metrics are good but to
what end like what what is this all
actually building towards and that's the
vision and the just cause how much you
think about what sort of tools and
approaches and what makes the people the
best leaders for for their colleagues in
the organization well as you said the
primary responsibility of a leader is to
build new leaders you know and one of
the ways we do that is we teach
leadership you know when somebody joins
a company we give them lots and lots of
education on the product and how the
company works and how the systems work
and we give them mentors and all of
these things but if we promote someone
to a position of leadership we usually
give them little to nothing and yet
leadership is a skill like any other we
don't expect them to be good at their
job unless we train them how to do their
job so how do we expect them to be good
leaders if we don't train them how to be
leaders you know are we teaching things
like how to give and receive feedback
how to do active listening how to have
an effective confrontation I'd have a
difficult conversation like these are
leadership skills and the motivation do
you think then you really have to figure
out a way to go back to that kind of
core values that's going to give people
that direction
what are you seeing right now that
people are doing to best motivate in
this crazy time we have with covid and
let's face it there is a malaise you
know over the whole world well I think a
big part of it is empathy quite frankly
which is you know do people feel seen
and heard
um you know when covet first struck
people in leadership positions whether
they were effective or ineffective
leaders prior to covid they sort of lean
back on their own humanity and they
picked up the phone and they picked you
know they called their team members one
by one and said are you okay but I think
this concept of the humanity that you
hit on like I think it's what's special
to me you know about DocuSign in the end
of the day and one and one of the
secrets to building trust by the way is
not offering your help uh to others but
asking for help from Others When leaders
say I don't know or I need your help yes
it's it's more likely to create the same
kind of behavior from the people who
work with them too it's interesting to
think about that construct we're having
where there is this sort of kova-driven
malaise but in some ways I think it's
even more than that I think it's what
you've talked so much about about a
purpose and people sort of thirsty for
that purpose and when the whole world
gets changed as it has been changed we
think differently and we've been talking
a lot about this idea of the great
Embrace and how do we create an
environment and culture where people say
I want to be a part of that what's your
sense about where you see people who are
doing a great job at that inspiring
people to say yeah let me come be part
of that family one of the things that we
don't talk about with the great
resignation is
um you know we talk about the fact that
some people are leaving because they've
got government checks that's a very
small percentage you know some people
are leaving because they want to follow
their dreams and this is not what they
want to do for the rest of their lives
that's true too that's also a relatively
small percentage I think the the larger
percentage quite frankly
um are are people who they've been
taking advantage of as a population for
for decades let's be honest and
companies have gotten away with it you
know so many people for most of their
lives if you ask them how's your job
they go it's fine you know and yet they
don't would you quit yeah but you know
they're more afraid of the unknown and
we went through covid where some people
were furloughed some people were laid
off uh some people didn't lose their
jobs they kept their jobs but they had
fear all of a sudden we realized we got
through it like we made it through it
and so when I'm faced with fine or the
unknown
um all of a sudden the unknown is much
more appealing I think people are
willing to go on a search and I think
we've had massive imbalance
um in corporate culture for decades
where we've largely taken advantage of
people and and now this is a great
correction the indictment is is that we
haven't focused on culture enough in
Corporate America for too long and I and
I think the companies that really have
focused on culture they're suffering a
lot less uh with the great resignation
jobs are like children right you don't
have to like your kids every day but you
could love your kids every day and you
don't have to like your job every day
but you get to love your job every day
and that that really is the
responsibility of the company
so thank you so much for joining us it's
been fantastic and thank you for helping
us kick this session off it's just
awesome my pleasure thanks so much for
having me uh take care of yourself take
care of each other